I got a story for you about a stirrer
damn yeah yeah I had a girlfriend who
went there oh no what happened she was a
naughty girl she was a [ __ ] naughty
girl and I loved her yeah I lived with
her okay and she was hanging out with a
guy okay and there was an older
gentleman tall he was dressed in she
said he looked like a Buccaneer he was
dressed in like kind of knickers with
boots
he had a stunt he had a monocle I cannot
a monocle but he had a a watch chain
with a watch and he was really well
dressed and he had a cane but he didn't
have a limp and he was kind of like this
he had a top hat like a [ __ ] magician
but handsome and older and she goes it
became very clear that he was sort of
the the the Fagin esque
leader of this bar like everyone knew
him and he had money and then I found
that that he had a legendary [ __ ] his
[ __ ] was enormous that that word around
town or she told and she said no no his
friend said heard the guy she was kind
of [ __ ] was friends with him and she
realized that he was she was kind of
being presented to him uh-huh
and I said as I swallow it and I was
like what happened next and she said I'm
not turned on well I was very interested
in how big his coffee turns out let's
figure it out he said to her she said I
hear you have a huge [ __ ] what he said
well there's only one way to find out
and apparently she sucked them yes in
the bar no on the on the veranda of the
bar outside yes and then what she did
her job yeah and then and then mobile on
her blanket side yep and he brought her
back inside and they had drinks and
laughed and then she went home with the
GI dude yeah did the other dudes know of
course he said of course he did sperm al
yeah he presented her to but after
you've been drinking whiskey all my fun
and stuff kills and
right so he was she presented and she
was such a champ
she was down for the [ __ ] adventure
what happened she's a badass
but she's still alive she's of course
she's still alive she's doing great
is she yeah I know her no she's one of
the best she's one she's she hold on it
sounds like the Beth yeah yeah the
outlaw I used to call her the outlaw who
she was a traveler a gypsy out one of
the best one of the best and that was
your girlfriend though she was she was
somebody I love she was hot yep yeah
I've had some yes yeah yeah yeah my
girlfriend yeah yeah we had been over we
had an over but by the way you know me
oh hey like if I was living with her
it's still her and she told me that
story we're welcoming her back
it would appear there would have been a
bad punishment oh yeah got it we got to
pay the piper now I've been into the
piper I'm gonna need dimensions I'm
gonna need everything I'm gonna need
diagrams but you should come here I love
you more I love you more by the way my
tools might might love you more that
you've got that sense of it listen I
want my quarterback through a few
interceptions you I'm saying I mean
right I'm not that possessed there's
more animals here I saw this holy [ __ ]
it looks like it's uh it's kind of cruel
it seems there's just a bunch of
photographers and they're following this
orangutan a giant orangutan who tell me
they're really docile better they're
really tall so that they're feeling this
chill and he's standing up that's god
I'd love to see those print those people
but that looks like it's is a sanctuary
look at this dude how's the National
Park is that code is towards the camera
dude so there's that and then this is
for the side so this is just a video of
him walking he was standing up so it
look like kind of like super tomato
though huh look at it though you don't
attack him or anything now he's coming
towards him you know I mean and the
other ones gone into the woods and this
thing is when I was on the trail dude I
see like there that looks trippy that
would be like Bigfoot but a tiny Bigfoot
look at how long it's not anything cool
and then check out this bison that runs
by a people on a truck and Yellowstone
National Park we'll call fast isn't it
hit anybody look at the beauty of it
watch it's so scary if it was going this
fast if you hit the truck boom fastest
way did he like people yeah then big
strong over 2,000 pounds running that
fast yeah you're right next to trouble
bang some trouble you can imagine what
it'd be like yeah and lastly I didn't
know about his hannel more animal
hurting or somebody like me hit but
though these I've never seen animals
this adorable and they're in Australia
so when you watch Austria you have to
check these oh ho cus he looks friendly
right ah are they mean though no they're
actually super friendly but you're not
supposed to touch him why not you're not
I guess that's the rule there maybe you
don't want to get too comfortable with
human beings they don't want them to why
I think it's cute I don't you probably
know I would love her so well look how
cute these things are and let us love a
pet they look so friendly but the only
downfall of these animals is that the
mothers they have like a few Joey's and
if they're chased by a predator what do
you think they do so she can escape what
a selfish I know that's always sad part
about it but they're adorable
take my baby not me look at their faces
they're so friendly hey is that J shop
that's that thing is cute I want one
I'll take one can you buy them they do
look like my brother a little bit hey
see if they're on sale no you can't
they're from for salad car the Blackwell
the Hedgehog looks like those those a
little bit with the pointy irnos though
but these guys have like a real
legitimate
happy like this my friend they're really
cute daddy doesn't doesn't watch porn
wha it seemed a little pent up I never
watched porn Wow and I haven't watched
porn in maybe you'll be here done yeah
my car man do it every day and it's got
to be black yeah I don't know how do you
do it you wouldn't you imagination like
eighth grade style III I'm older I just
I don't know yeah I don't think back to
I don't even turn golf in black and
white I swear to God what I'm just get
the [ __ ] out you're sitting you're weird
that's better than yeah now cuz my dad
looked at my history about it was
probably six years ago and he looked at
my I was traveling at the house and he
looks at my [ __ ] computer and he goes
what is this yeah he put in something
and he goes what is this porn porn black
guy so I go oh I watch porn yeah I think
Jesus are you single mark no I got a hot
hot lady at home oh really oh yeah now
do you do announce it out there on on
Instagram and stuff yeah anything get in
trouble if you don't ya know I don't
care like to me I just want to like plug
gigs and she's like you gotta show
people and I'm like alright alright so
annoying I just I don't want to do
social media I just do it to get seats
you know yeah I wish I didn't have to
its brutal brutal I got some friends who
don't do it and they're so much happier
they're just what are they selling
tickets sell do like Nate bargatze pays
a lady to do all that [ __ ] you don't
wanna do that my whole life change with
that special of course which is rare now
he's gonna come on the podcast he's
great but like there's a few guys who
don't do socialite I have cat run most
of it my brother and then I'll
definitely check in but it is it's so
toxic man yeah yeah and just the effort
that you put into it
wait so you're seeing his DMS oh yeah
hopefully not all yeah you're a hot hunk
of meat there sir Oh
shop shop yeah yeah look at that thigh
alone could feed a family ladies the
ladies like nowhere tell us about your
your thicky
they call him a thick E I must I was
sitting with these girls I was sitting
this girl kept going on three things
he's that picky and he's so cute yeah
they like good hair line good car great
youth
yeah and you're always trying to lose
weight don't lose
just be big your thick crust yeah they
don't demolish there should be went the
name of my new tour thick crust yeah
deep dish I just like thick crust greasy
Davidoff oh yeah you really did really I
like it allows me so much of yeah
interesting huh how do you figure he's a
junkyard guy right he was quite a
swinger in his day if I might swing yeah
I I've had some I've had some time oh
you did the row with him for a while
over close I dove and I did it right wow
that's quite a threesome I would say
you're gonna gal in the middle of that
sandwich by the way he's working with a
field bass for Oh easy yeah he's got a
piece on him oh that's intimidating dove
nope not for me but I know you man by
the way never forget who that who who
daddy is I mean at the end of the day I
was old the bottom line is that dove one
alpha dove is a special dude and has the
darkness and has all the you remind me
he's doing comedy is he's back in right
he's in he's in New York you see oh yeah
all the time yes hilarious and he's got
his own thing he sounds very no one
sounds like duh yeah jasmine yes he is
jesse is he's got a little jazz and sri
ice you were just showed they're on to
such a different frequency liked of like
fee oh yeah just I'm never gonna hear
this anywhere else
yeah there's a good common good
comparison to cuz just so it's like a
unique sound it's like when the
Hitchcock guitar right two places are
you know it's the air yeah the same like
some people have that [ __ ] that yeah
that just a doozy yeah yeah it's a
different vibe hasn't heard it before
and the weird thing about that is
starting out with a different fruit like
jazel neck either you really struggle
starting I always be like what is this
[ __ ] but you know give it a second [ __ ]
it's gonna get into separate you just
gotta go with me trust me
you know that's why I hate the industry
they can't see that then when they the
person figures it out and they get good
in Chicago we love you we always a big
fan like shut up Nick is a
big fan big fan he's the best he's proof
that you can say whatever you want beat
dark as long as it's a bit no one gives
a [ __ ] god he is dark two men have never
killed anyone then I remembered Jennifer
he really is yeah my he's like can I buy
a motorcycle his mom's like now your
brother died on a motorcycle so don't
buy you can just have his brilliant
trouble lesson I don't want to say her
name but there was a large black woman I
went on and I had to follow her and I
said give it up for ron funches
you know and the place went nuts but she
went she was not into it
just just to get a laugh out of yes
nothing against you I like you am wrong
but I thought was a perfect line yeah
you could [ __ ] on me all day you know I
get robot and you know weirdo autism you
know go nuts you're a [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] breath of fresh air in this in
this politically correct brain-dead Los
Angeles it on the road with Burt oh man
open up for Burt and you're in Europe 14
nights 14 countries 14 or I guess 28
shows I mean no break no no I think we
had one day off and we went to some
strip club and Copenhagen and had a
[ __ ] blast and he was like facetiming
his wife while getting lapped yeah it
was insane so married but he is very
married but I don't like he knows his
kids names it was just so like I took
three years off my life I was telling
you that one kid came out the last two
days and he was like after the first
night he just was like I'm going home
and I was like I did 14 you [ __ ] come
on just keep it up with Burt he's like a
70s celebrity he's eating a steak at
[ __ ] 11:00 a.m. drinking a scotch
then he goes and works out and then he
comes back and does like ten marketing
things he's editing a video he's
shooting [ __ ] and then we do the set and
he gets blotto all night and then he
does it the next day
monster the monster mantle gene he's got
the Mickey Mantle